so we talked to talked about the blood
oxygen stuff
um hot bass don't eat after six no
caffeine after so
unless you get your DNA check to see how
efficient your body is at metabolizing
caffeine out of your body you won't know
if it's three hours four hours or eight
hours uh if if your body metabolizes
caffeine very slowly it could be as long
as seven to eight hours for me I've had
my DNA tested and I know that I
metabolize caffeine very very quickly
so I could have a coffee at four or five
o'clock in the afternoon and still sleep
no problem so my advice is no caffeine
unless you know you know how fast your
body metabolizes it for somewhere
between six to six to eight hours before
bed
um for me I have like one or two coffees
in the morning that's generally it
sometimes I have a decaf in the
afternoon just because I like the taste
of coffee but no caffeine before bed or
anywhere close to bedtime is a strong
recommendation by all experts Do It
um another one that I found was very
very interesting
and it's hard to do in the wintertime
but getting sunlight in the early
morning and the late afternoon
um getting the blue light into your
eyeballs is apparently very very
effective
um I don't remember the podcast I was
listening to but
um some of the oldest
um
items in your eye butchering this
obviously because I paid attention so
[ __ ] long ago but
some of the oldest
um like components of your eyeball
itself
go back before eyeballs were even used
to see anything like before your eye
form this structure because it's really
an extension of your brain like your eye
is actually part of your brain it's not
separate from your brain it's actually
part of your brain it's just like like
your brain squished it out and forward
to the front of your head so you could
see [ __ ] and one of the earliest uses of
that was to detect Blue Light which was
to tell you to get up in the morning and
when to go to sleep at night time so
it's incredibly important to get blue
light apparently on this part of your
eyeball in the morning and late
afternoon so when the sun's coming up I
I always do this in the spring summer
and fall it's harder to do in the winter
time because it's cold as [ __ ] you don't
want to go outside and everybody's got
their excuses myself included but
ideally get out look at the sun rising I
mean don't look directly at it like if
this is the camera for example is the
sun then I would basically kind of like
look over here or I would look slightly
over here I wouldn't look directly at
the sun
um but looking in the in the general
direction of the Sun for like 10 12 15
minutes is apparently what what you need
resets your resets your circadian rhythm
to tell your body okay it's wakey time
we have [ __ ] to do give me all the
hormones that I need to do [ __ ] to have
energy to be productive to be focused
and all that sort of thing and then the
same thing at the end of the day as the
sun's going down and it's low on the
horizon and interestingly it's always
when it's low on the horizon that it's
important to do this so in the morning
and then again at the end of the day
when it's low on the horizon look at the
sunset same sort of thing Sun's over
there you spend you know 12 15 minutes
just looking at its general direction
admire you know the trees the clouds
whatever it happens to be that helps
reset your circadian rhythm so that your
body is a 2 soon you know if you will or
or calibrate it to understand okay it's
getting dark the sun's going down it's
time to you know turn off systems slow
down systems and get ready to go to
sleep it's time to produce melatonin and
all that sort of stuff so
it works I mean it sounds goofy as [ __ ]
but trust me
ever since I heard about that I do that
as often as I can
um again it sounds goofy but I'm the guy
that is out there you know looking at
the Sunrise and the sunsets that's just
me
um another thing that I learned is uh
booze and weed like it's not only just
bad for your body in general and for
productivity and for your organs like
there's no real upside I got a video
that I did the other day on um uh booze
which is going to be published in the
entrepreneurs and cars channel in the
next week or so I get into more depth so
I'm not gonna belabor the issue but
um your body is unable to get into deep
restful sleep when you have booze and
weed in your system it interrupts it and
I can factually speak to this because my
aura ring okay these things I don't know
they're like three or four hundred bucks
um that's what this ring is it's got
little sensors on the bottom I can't
pull it off my finger because it's too
snug right now at the end of the day but
um it's got these sensors on the bottom
and it tracks all of your data and it
tells me whether I'm getting quality
restful sleep or I'm not and if I've
been out drinking you know the Dube gets
passed around sort of thing the quality
of my sleep drops dramatically I don't
get restful sleep it's absolutely 100
correct and right so now I mean I tend
to avoid that
um for me again deep restful proper
sleep is more important than you let's
party it up and get stoned on sort of
[ __ ] all the time you know it's a time
and place when it can be fun you know
from time to time when you're hanging
out with people and you know the right
moment uh you know used you know
gingerly if you will but it will
interrupt your sleep so if you're one of
these guys that thinks that you know you
need to smoke a joint before you go to
bed or have a glass of whatever before
you go to sleep it will interrupt your
sleep it will absolutely positively
disrupt your sleep and at the best you
may sleep throughout the night but you
won't get deep restful REM sleep right
which is what your body needs so take it
for what it's worth listen to me don't
listen to me doesn't matter to me it's
up to you
um next point I got is a weighted
blanket sounds goofy but it works
um I Heard for years people telling me
Oh you got to get a weighted blanket
they're awesome you'll sleep better I
was like Yeah well yeah whatever
whatever and it's like I was going
through all this stuff anyway and when I
ordered my uh chili pad which I'll talk
talk about in a little bit
um I got a weighted blanket at the same
time and it's honestly it's it's awesome
you know I should have bought it sooner
they're not expensive they're just like
these blankets that have um I think
they're weighted uh I don't know if
they're lead or or heavy silicone or
something but they but they have like
these little beads in them that are
heavy and I don't know if you've um you
know ever seen a kid swaddle like a baby
swaddled but babies when they're small
you basically swaddle them like you
basically wrap them up like a burrito
and they're like sitting here like this
sort of thing and that that that
Comforts them and it makes them go to
sleep and there's something about having
some degree of pressure or weight on
your body that puts you into a a state
of relaxation and
[Music]
contributes to deeper more restful sleep
I don't know what it is sounds goofy as
[ __ ] but it works it's that whole
swaddling thing from when you're a baby
it just reminds your body Comfort you're
warm close your eyes relax go to sleep
it works um weighted blankets I
definitely endorse them go out and get
one
um talked about the spo2 monitor talked
about a sleep study I will say this with
the sleep study
um I don't know if all the places are
like this obviously I just went to the
one that I went to what you do is you is
you go there you go through a full prep
the questionnaire blah blah blah all the
[ __ ] they take your height your weight
they you know they have this room that
they kind of walk you through and
there's like every like there's all
these medical students at these stations
and they monitor like three rooms you
know each you know for example
and they walk you to this room which is
the shittiest most uncomfortable room
possible the mattress sucks the [ __ ]
Decor it's like an office with like roof
tiles
it's just a dog [ __ ] place it's it's not
a comfortable place it's not a welcome
in place you know if I can put it that
way it's definitely not my bedroom it's
not a nice hotel room it's [ __ ] the
pillows suck the bed sucks and then
after all of that they wire you up they
basically put
I don't know 50 50 wires on you maybe
maybe a little bit more from from
essentially your head to your toe you've
got all these wires all over your body
tracking uh pulse rate movement uh blood
oxygen levels brain wave activity
probably all this [ __ ] so you're in
an uncomfortable room that's not cool
without a weighted blanket without a
chili pad with a shitty mattress crappy
pillows
um it's just an awkward place you're not
going to get great sleep there I'm going
to tell you straight off the bat you're
probably going to get a worse sleep
score in one of the sleep study rooms
than you will in your bedroom and I
think there's a reason for that because
I was talking to my massage therapist
about this you know before I went to it
and she goes everybody that leaves the
sleep study Clinic comes out with a CPAP
machine they want to sell you a [ __ ]
CPAP machine in Canada the government
covers like two-thirds of the costs and
like money's not a problem for me
obviously so I don't give a [ __ ] anyway
but like I got to see Pat machine I'll
talk about that in a minute but the
sleep study will tell you how you're
sleeping if you're on your back if
you're on your side if you're on your
stomach what percentage of the time what
your blood oxygen levels are if you're
snoring how loud you're snoring what
your blood oxygen levels are at each you
know sleep apnea event how many sleep
apnea events you have throughout the
night again
I believe that it collects a lot of data
but I also believe at the same time that
it's also designed to make sure that you
get worse sleep than you would in your
own bedroom I really wish they would
have a more welcoming room for you or at
least let you plug in something at your
house and collect the data from your own
room but they don't you have to go to
these places and the data they collect
is pretty [ __ ] scary right it's it's
like holy [ __ ] you know you're not
breathing this number of times per hour
uh you're snoring at this volume
I also slept in my back something like I
think 42 percent of the time and I never
sleep on my back when I'm at home I
always sleep on my sides
um so I was probably sleeping on my back
due to the discomfort of all the [ __ ]
wires and [ __ ] when you sleep on your
back you're more prone to snore and not
get good healthy blood oxygen levels so
take it for what it's worth
um you know try to accommodate for that
knowing it if you ever do a sleep study
but it's it's
um it is what it is right it's it's it's
a useful tool but I also believe that
they're also designed you know as a
function of society as I like to say
plugged into the code of the Matrix you
know when you see the code of the Matrix
is everywhere it's not just Wham and
it's not just money it's not just all of
these things they want you [ __ ] under
control and
um you know if they can plug you into
their [ __ ] and tell you that you're [ __ ]
and you have to use their [ __ ] then
they're going to sell it to you
um it is what it is anyway
done with the sleep study
that was around February
I get the results 90 days later
and then they say uh you know we're
gonna script you a CPAP machine find
whatever
um you know so I ordered one of those
that took like seven months to get they
basically called me and I was like who
are you and what are you calling me for
was literally that long it was almost 10
months later so I got the CPAP machine
they suck uh they're uncomfortable at
first but
um I do track my blood oxygen or I was
tracking it with a Loki that I had
um for a good two months while I had the
CPAP and I wouldn't say there was a
dramatic Improvement in the blood oxygen
levels but one to two percent higher
like if I was averaging 94 blood oxygen
I'm now averaging 96 to 97 percent so
that's a good Improvement
um they're not that comfortable they're
kind of hard to get used so they have
all kinds of different masks and things
that they want you to try at the end of
the day I ended up settling with like
this nose pillow mask where it's
basically these two things that go up
your nose and the thing kind of goes
over your head
um and it's like a leaf blower
um it just kind of like you know blows
air into your nostrils uh when you're
inhaling and then when you're exhaling
then it just relieves the pressure so
you can exhale uh it does help it's
quiet it doesn't make any noise you get
used to it within a few weeks
um I I can still sleep without it like
when I travel down to Mexico uh the
other week I don't even bother bringing
it with me even though they say that you
can or that you should bring it with you
at all times but it's like
I didn't bother bring it I still slept
okay but um yeah so I use the CPAP now
um I took that on Derek's advice for
more plates more dates because you know
you said he uses one and you know he's
talking about it in depth and I'm like
yeah that that makes sense like I've
I've seen the writing on the wall like
you know I've seen the blood oxygen
levels not being that great sometimes
I've woken up before gasping for air
that [ __ ] sucks that's scary as [ __ ]
um so hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out